all aboard the hype train let's go hey
what is up guys mkbhd here and welcome
to top 5 tech to look forward to in
2016. no one's probably gonna watch this
video in 2017 but it doesn't matter
let's get into it so number one is the
samsung galaxy s7 and this is a
smartphone we're going to see pretty
soon it's going to be announced on
february 21st right around the corner
and this is probably going to be a bunch
of classic high-end samsung android
smartphone stuff so we'll probably see
snapdragon 820 will probably have at
least four gigabytes of ram and it's
rumored to be using the 25 megapixel imx
300 sensor that's currently in sony's
xperia z5 premium so a high end camera
and the design is likely to be pretty
similar to the galaxy s6 and galaxy s6
edge but samsung does like to go a
little bit crazy at least somewhere down
the line so we can probably expect to
see at least one oddball new feature in
the galaxy s7 now whether this is
something as simple as a usb type c port
or bringing back a micro sd card slot or
something more drastic like a 4k display
or maybe a pressure sensitive display
like we have with force touch in the
iphone either way the galaxy s7 is about
to be everywhere quick number two is the
iphone 7. there are many possible rumors
about the next iphone besides the lack
of a headphone jack uh but the most
important thing is that it's a new
design change iphone 6 is a new design
iphone 6s is improved inside iphone 7 is
a new design again and we've heard
rumors of things like a cleaned up
design removed antenna lines maybe
removing the camera bump and also a lack
of a headphone jack and dac inside could
mean we could see little things like a
little bit of a bigger speaker or a
little bit of a bigger battery other
little design changes could include
tossing in a little bit of extra water
resistance on the inside or maybe
throwing in wireless charging but all
this is wishful thinking and it's
reasonable to expect but if you want to
think outside the box a little bit you
could consider
rethinking the entire idea of the home
button on the iphone we know this is
where touch id lives but force touch has
opened up a lot of doors for what apple
can do with their next flagship also as
a bonus we could also see a smaller
iphone earlier this year iphone 5se a
new lower price four inch iphone with
updated specs and design kind of like a
refresh of that iphone 5c number three
is the next nexus possibly also known as
the nexus 7. again at this point in the
year we know almost nothing about the
next nexus what it'll look like what
it'll be called who will make it but
what we do know is nexus 6p was one of
the best android phones of 2015 and that
nexus 5x was a decent revival of nexus 5
and it was a pretty good budget stock
android option the next nexus whether
it's a nexus 7 or a nexus 6p2 or
whatever they decided to call it will
inevitably be a showcase of a clean
version of android n so it's always a
showcase for the next version of android
we should see this showing up around
quarter three so like september october
and this year and it's again it's kind
of like a two for one we're getting new
hardware with one or maybe two new nexus
phones and then new software with
android n number four is 4k oled so my
last few years of looking at tvs could
be summarized like this plenty of crispy
4k
none of them oled
plenty of beautiful oled tvs
none of them 4k but this year this year
we're gonna start to see a bunch more 4k
oled tvs first of all if you've seen any
of the oled 1080p tvs they already look
pretty awesome but i got a chance to
look at lg's 4k oled tv and it's easily
the best looking tv i've ever seen so
i'm excited to see more of those come
out this year i also heard murmurings of
a certain dell
30-inch 4k monitor have yet to see that
in person but i would love to take a
look at it dell and number five this
one's a little bit different tesla's
model three so the model s we already
know is an awesome car but it starts at
what about seventy thousand dollars and
then tesla model x the suv is also
pretty awesome came out recently but it
also starts at maybe eighty thousand
dollars so tesla model three which is
supposed to come out or at least be
showcased for the first time this year
supposed to start at 35 000 so for a
high-end electric car that's pretty
important and being able to get the
price down low is big for tesla and for
electric cars in general and part of the
reason they're able to do this is
because of the new factory they're
building the gigafactory which will
allow them to produce a bunch of parts
including batteries at an efficiency and
a scale that they haven't been able to
do before that being said all we're
really getting this year is the official
design and spec reveal of the car so
we'll get to see what it looks like
finally we'll finally get to see the
official numbers the price the
acceleration all those types of numbers
but we won't actually get to buy that
car until probably 2017. either way i'm
still pretty excited to see it mostly
because this is a pretty important
product like i said for tesla and it's
seen as sort of like an end game one of
the biggest goals for tesla as a company
was to bring electric cars to the masses
in an affordable way model s being the
showcase to get everyone's attention get
it on the radar and then model three
being one that people can actually get
so there you have it guys that's what
i'm looking forward to in tech in 2016.
i'll give some honorable mentions one to
the ipad air 4 or whatever the next gen
ipad air is as we've heard it may be a
4k display which would be kind of neat
considering most tablets have run up
against that barrier in the past couple
years
and galaxy note 6 because it will
inevitably be a little bit better than
the galaxy s7 also shout out to the desk
setup behind me if you're wondering
where i am right now you should watch
the video linked right there and see
exactly what this is all about some also
some dope tech in that video so what
kind of tech are you guys looking
forward to most this year same stuff
different stuff feel free to let me know
in the comment section right below that
like button and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
you